hello everyone and happy New Year
everyone we have a very very interesting
position here and as the title suggests
uh a mate in one is required although
seemingly an impossible one now I've set
up this video to be uploaded or rather
published at 2359 uh sort of the um you
know welcome you guys into into the new
year into the 2023 but that is only
possible if you share the time zone with
me if not you will have to wait for it a
little bit or you um I probably have
already celebrated it but if you are at
a party somewhere now watching this you
you will have uh definitely something to
show your your friends over at the party
especially if there's a nice chessboard
you can even set it up for everyone take
a take a photo with the with it and um
uh yeah it's going to be a great fun for
you guys and I'm I mean why why would
you be somewhere where there isn't the
chessboard at the party I I can't even
imagine that but okay let's return to
the position so as the title suggests it
is a mate in one uh although seemingly
an impossible one so have at it feel
free to pause the video and try to solve
this it's made in one so while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on successfully
thinking way outside of the box and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move is D captures on E6 Alpha
saw and that is the way to do it and now
a mate in one is delivered there is
nothing black can do as well you just
can't cover up you can play F6 because
the Rook prevents you from doing that
and any other moves are impossible the
bishop now also hits the G7 and h8 the
Knight covers a G8 and that means the
black king has nowhere to run so
interestingly the only way to solve this
position would be once you try to solve
it in a standard way you will realize
that it is impossible you need at least
two moves like even Queen captures and
G6 like the king to h8 and then Queen to
G8 will be Checkmate and then okay the
other uh solution will be that I'm
actually tricking you in the dead there
is no mate in one possible but why I
mean I would never do that so once you
figure that out then you would have to
think okay let's go uh go move back and
then you would have to think what was
Black's last move and then you would of
course figure out that Black's last move
was Pawn to E5 and that made all of this
possible so E5 and the only way to win
the game with black and one it would
white in one move D captures on E6 and
what a spectacular Checkmate so I sort
of tricked you a little bit but not
really the mating one was possible you
just have to you you just had to it was
a rare case of where to solve the
position you didn't have to see many
moves ahead but you had to see one move
backwards so hopefully you were able to
do that if not you have something very
awesome to show your friends at the bar
and the library uh so yeah that's the
game or rather the the fun position that
I prepared for you guys hope you enjoyed
that and wish you all the best in in the
New Year 2023 uh hope it's gonna be a
much better one and then than the
previous one even though uh probably
your your year was a rather okay or
maybe even um more than impressive I
hope it will be even better than that
and that we will have many many great
chess events and that you will improve
your game and that you will you know
play many many Immortal games uh so yeah
pretty uh pretty short stuff hope you
guys enjoyed that as usual I would like
to thank Adam Holt James Mayberry Louis
Michael Hoff Consulting and William
Fuller for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on everything
that's been happening in the Chess World
and of course on your uh incredible
suggestions as they always brighten up
my day so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and an excellent rest of the year